hace dos meses este hombre lo perdió
todo en el corazón de estas montañas de
tigre soldados eritreos masacraron a
varias personas de su pueblo escondidas
en un hueco de un acantilado estas
tumbas son el único rastro visible que
queda de la matanza
era mi mujer su oficio es madre de cinco
niños le dio vida a un bebé hace un mes
también teníamos hijas llamaban celac su
fan israel no pudimos rezar por eso
porque tuvimos que huir para salvar
nuestras vidas
ese día un gran número de soldados en y
treos ingresaron a nuestro pueblo
imposible decir cuántos eran los
habitantes se encerraron en sus casas
pero los soldados vinieron a buscarlos o
se agruparon aquí y los masacraron a
todos desde el principio del conflicto
soldados eritreos apoyan al ejército
etíope contra las fuerzas disidentes del
tigre numerosos testigos acusan a los
eritreos de haber perpetrado masacres y
violaciones por toda la región como aquí
la mayoría de las zonas rurales son
difícilmente accesibles a las ong debido
al conflicto este equipo médico debe con
frecuencia replegarse a la capital
incluso cuando no hay combates los
desplazamientos son limitados hoy
habíamos previsto ir a algunos pueblos y
los vecinos nos esperaban pero en el
camino fuimos controlados por soldados
etíopes que nos impidieron pasar les
explicamos que atendemos a las mujeres y
a los niños estamos muy preocupados por
ellos que viven en los pueblos que nos
necesitan
el equipo se detiene finalmente en este
pequeño pueblo en pleno centro de tigre
las necesidades en salud son importa
en la zona porque aquí el centro de
atención fue atacado este centro se
ocupaba de pacientes hasta mediados de
enero luego el ejército etíope lo
destruyó lo tomaron todo y lo dañaron
allá estaba la nevera la rompieron y la
dejaron ahí
botaron las vacunas y los medicamentos
destinados a los niños
es un desperdicio en estas regiones
rurales recibir un tratamiento médico se
volvió un lujo incluso obtener alimento
es difícil la desnutrición afecta
especialmente a los niños está perdiendo
peso tiene una orden para que puedas
recibir alimentos especiales
marianela debido a la falta de
ambulancias algunas mujeres mueren en
cama tal como la madre de este recién
nacido hace tres meses desde hace
algunos días su familia no ha podido
obtener leche su tía lo alimenta con
puré de cereales
vamos a pesar la tuvimos suerte de
encontrar a este bebé habríamos podido
no verlo si hubiésemos venido más tarde
hay muchos bebés como ella y las madres
no tienen leche estos niños son muy
pequeños y morirán pronto no contábamos
con los recursos para salvarnos
el bebé vive con su familia a unos
cuantos minutos caminando del pueblo su
padre hizo todo para salvar a su mujer
tras el parto sin otro medio de
transporte disponible tuvo que llevarla
en carreta al hospital más cercano
cuando llegamos a la ciudad no había
nada estaba vacía aún no encontramos a
nadie para ayudarnos y falleció erramos
con su cuerpo esperamos una hora y media
ahora que perdí a mi mujer no puedo
trabajar mi situación es difícil cómo
cuidar a mis hijos
esta familia vive en la hambruna sólo le
quedan estas bolsas de cereales casi
vacíos sin embargo este hombre es
campesino pero entre la pérdida de su
mujer y el conflicto no pudo trabajar a
tiempo para la temporada
en la región numerosos agricultores
están en la misma situación lo que
acentúa la inseguridad alimentaria
creando algo
hacia el mes de noviembre empezó vivimos
con estos problemas nuestros enemigos
vinieron y el trabajo fue interrumpido
tuvimos que huir hacia otros lugares
entonces no trabaje el campo antes de la
temporada de lluvias
winehouse en la ciudad más cercana al
pueblo está desierta la economía está
detenida para ayudar a los más
desfavorecidos hay organizaciones a
veces apoyadas por el gobierno que
tratan de distribuir trigo y semillas
tenemos cerca de 3.000 quintales de
semillas que pondremos a disposición de
más de 12 mil agricultores llegaremos a
las personas más vulnerables pero ello
nos cubre a toda la población
el cese al fuego unilateral declarado
por el gobierno el 28 de junio deja
entrever una situación humanitaria muy
preocupante según la onu 350.000
personas están en situación de hambruna
en tigre